okay welcome everybody come on in thanks
so much for joining me today my name is
Brandon minck and in this session we're
talking about how to correct common
mistakes in async and await now I am so
excited to be here with you today
because this is a talk that actually
made back in 2018 gave it for the first
time at NDC Sydney so it's super cool to
come all the way back to Copenhagen and
deliver it but there's been a lot more
cool stuff add it to net since 2018 so
it was an hour talk back then it's about
an hour and a half talk now that we're
just going to cram into an hour so I'm
going to move fast but the good news is
I've got a link down here on the slides
you'll see this link you'll see this QR
code takes you to the same place this is
where you can find everything that we're
going to talk about today so we've got
some open source code all that's up on
GitHub you can find it at the website
that's where you can find the slides you
can even find the recording from I also
did this talk at NDC Oslo a couple years
ago as well so don't worry about trying
to take notes don't worry about trying
to keep up don't worry about trying to
memorize anything because we got a lot
of stuff to cover and it's all there for
you so make sure to grab a picture of
that QR code and feel free to share it
with friends and co-workers who maybe
couldn't be here today but let's get
rolling so we're going to start by
looking at this method this is a async
task method called red dat from URL and
yes I made this six years ago so it's a
little out of date but if you ignore the
fact that we're using web client because
yes today you should be using HTTP
client you should never knew up a new
HTTP client inside a method that should
be static you should be reusing them
we've got HTTP client Factory now but
we're still using it in this example
just because you'll see in a bit we dive
real deep into this code and these are
really complex slides that take a lot of
work to put together but what we're
doing here is we are new up a a web
client we're calling download data task
async we're returning that as a bite
array called result en encoding that
into a string data and then passing that
to a method called load data now what's
really going on here with with async AWA
with multi-threading is
that the first thread is going to call
this chunk of code so let's say thread
one calls this code so thread one comes
in it news up web client it initializes
bite array result and then it hits that
await keyword and as soon as our thread
hits the awake
keyword it goes away it it returns and
that's important because thread one is
also known as the main thread it's also
known as the UI thread it's the most
important thread in our apps because
it's the only thread that can interact
with the UI it's the only thread that
can interact with the user when the user
Taps a button on our app it's the UI
thread that reacts and fires off that uh
click Handler uh when the user Scrolls
on the screen it's the UI thread that
has to redraw everything on the screen
while the user scrolling so if thread
one was calling download data task async
it'd be really bad because if download
data task async takes 5 Seconds well
then the user can't interact with our
app for 5 seconds and our app's
basically Frozen and what happens when
our app freezes well what do they do
they force quit the app they give us a
onear review in the app store they tell
their friends don't use this app it's
crap it freezes all the time when really
all that's happening is we accidentally
locked up the main thread the calling
thread so good news with asyn of we as
soon as we hit the await keyword that
calling thread in this case thread one
returns it's able to now interact with
the user the user can tap buttons all
the meanwhile thread 2 in this case is
running in the background now it's not
always going to be thread 2 uh what
happens under the hood is do net just
goes and grabs any thread from the thre
any thread from the thread pool uh we've
got this cool thing inet called thread
pools where depending on the size of
your computer your server your phone
whatever your app code is running on uh
that'll determine how many threads you
have in the thread pool so in this case
we got thread 2 it's running download
data task async and then when it
finishes net goes back to the calling
thread in this case thread one and says
hey thread one you're back up so thread
one jumps back in picks up where it left
off and it does the encoding to turn
that into a string and then it jumps
into load data now we're going to go a
little deeper and to go a little deeper
we've got to see what the compiler
actually generat Ates out of our code so
here's that here's that method again and
this is actually what it looks like
after we compile uh so if you're not
familiar umet when you click compile it
turns your C code into a dll file and
sometimes it does some compiler gener
generated stuff for us which is what
we're looking at here and if you ever
wanted to you can use a decompiler to
take that dll and convert it back into C
code so we're looking back at C code
that was created by in the dll file and
then recreated by our decompiler and the
first thing you'll notice is we're
looking at a private sealed class called
the same as our method name read data
from URL now I didn't write a class I
wrote a method but the compiler took my
async method and turned it into a class
and this happens anytime we use the
async keyword so you might not realize
it but
every time we use that async keyword and
we add it on that little on the method
line on the meth method signature the
compilers got to work a little bit
harder to create this task or create
this class and our app size gets just a
little bit bigger because it generates
some code for us now that's all
insignificant for 99.9% of our projects
but just FYI it'll add a nanc to your
compile time and it'll increase your app
size by about a 100 bytes but I don't
know if you're like me who cares about
100 byes right like I'm a mobile app
developer I make IOS and Android apps
using zamarin and net Maui all and c and
I I don't care about H 100 byes but
maybe maybe you're making stuff for the
space shuttle and it's got to be really
optimized then you might care what else
is in here well we see a couple Fields
so a bunch of private fields and these
fields are actually the same variables
that we created inside our method so not
only does it generate a class but it
also takes those
local variables that we created and
turns them into Fields so you can see
there's private string data private bite
aray result private web client WC uh
public string URL because URL was the
parameter passed in so it's public and
something else you'll notice is these
weird angle brackets and underscores uh
the net compiler actually does that on
purpose because when it generates code
it doesn't want to generate anything
with a similar variable name that might
already exist in your code and so the
trick that the team does is it actually
creates illegal file names like if you
tried to create a field called angle
bracket data angle bracket 5or 3 it
wouldn't compile so that's how we can
kind of get away with creating that or
how the net team can get create away
with creating that for us and what else
do we have in here we've
got this method called move next now if
I'm being totally honest with you this
is what started my journey down the
async weight rabbit hole about six seven
eight years ago because I pushed my
first app to the app store around that
time and I kept seeing these weird
errors like weird things were happening
in my app that I didn't tell it to do
and I had no idea what was going on and
and a lot of my stack traces was move
next and I'm like what is this I I never
wrote a method called move next so how
is this move next appearing in all my
stack traces um well it's because it was
autogenerated for me and if we dive into
move move
next this is what it looks like but
let's zoom in move next is basically a
state machine so to boil that down into
C terms move next is just a giant switch
statement and it creates a case every
time we use the await keyword so in our
instance
here we have two cases and that's
because in the method I wrote I call the
awake keyword once
if in My Method I had called the awake
keyword twice we would have three cases
if I had used the awake keyword three
times we would have four cases so every
time we use that a keyword we get a new
case inside of move next inside of our
state machine and if we look at the code
case zero this is all the code leading
up to that first await so just like we
saw earlier it's newing up web client
and then it's calling download data task
async kind of uh really what it's doing
it's getting the this what's it's called
an a waiter and not to go into too much
detail but that's basically how thread
one will know where to come back but
then thread one returns so we hit this
return statement and this is actually
the magic that frees up that calling
thread once it hits the awake keyword
because thread one as far as it knows it
returned it's done it exits the method
and now our main thread is able to go
back and our users can use our app and
not have to worry about it freezing up
but before it returns it sets that value
of PC to one and it does that because
when net comes back to thread one and
says hey the background task is done
you're back
up thread one's going to jump back into
case one so it's kind of letting itself
know where to pick up where it left off
and just like we expect this is the rest
of our method where we we get the result
from download data task async we encode
it and then we call that load data
method now the other weird thing inside
a move next is this this Tri catch block
and I guarantee you everybody in this
room if you've written asyn A8 code
you've been burned by this Tri catch
block myself included and what's what's
weird about this is I didn't write a TR
catch block right there's no TR catch
block and my code this is all
autogenerated for us and it's always
autogenerated for us and so what this
means is if any of my code throws an
exception it's going to get caught right
here now the good news is if we use the
awake
keyword the awake keyword will
essentially rethrow the exception so
when Say thread one comes back to see
hey what what happened how'd everything
go where do I pick up or I left off it
goes oh there's an exception it'll
rethrow it so as long as we use the
awake keyword we're good but the biggest
problem I see and this was actually my
problem back in the day when I made my
first app was we try to be too clever
you know I was I was was making a mobile
app and just like we were talking about
a minute ago I didn't want to hog the UI
thread so I thought I was being real
smart saying I'm going to put this on a
background thread by saying task.run
here's all my code and you know what
it's on the background I don't care when
it finishes so I'm not going to wait
task. run and what was happening what
the reason I was getting weird behavior
in my app and weird bugs and weird stack
traces is that exception or an exception
was being thrown in my code but it was
being caught here in decid to move next
and because I didn't await that task
that exception never got rethrown and
you might think to yourself isn't that a
good thing exceptions crash our apps I
try my best to not have exceptions and
you're not totally wrong but I would
argue exceptions are a good thing
because it lets us know as developers
that hey something happened that we
didn't want something happened
unexpected something exceptional
happened and it's kind of C's way of
letting us know or Net's way of asking
us hey what do you want to do with this
so for me my app was throwing exceptions
I was not awaiting my task I thought I
was being smart by running stuff inside
the background thread doing test out run
and all of a sudden now my app's in this
weird state that I never designed it for
I never programmed it for and you get
really really weird bugs all because of
try catch so let's do a quick review
before we jump into some code so the
async keyword adds about 100 bytes so
every time we create a new async method
again the compiler creates a class for
us and it increases our app size by just
a little bit but again what's what's 100
bytes Worth to us in
2023 I don't really
mind and then the other thing we want to
remember we want to await every task
please don't ever do what I did don't
ever say task. run and just let it go
without awaiting it uh the other really
bad pattern I see all the time well not
all the time but way more often than we
should should is people do underscore
equals Tas out run like they're
discarding the task and you definitely
don't want to do that
because then there's no way to get that
exception back if one bubbles up so make
sure we await every task otherwise these
non- awaited tasks are going to hide
exceptions all right so let's jump into
some code here and like I said this is
all this is all open source it's up on
GitHub if you didn't get a chance to
grab that link I'll share it with you
later
but what we're going to do here is we're
going to take this this app I've created
um I don't know if anybody reads Hacker
News but it's a cool website I like that
people can post Tech news stories to so
this is just a mobile app that hits
hacker news's apis pulls down the top
stories and then you know we can click
on any of these and we can read it here
in our browser without having to go to
the
website so what I've got here is this is
a AET Maui app obviously all written in
C and again don't worry about memorizing
anything because I've got this file bad
asyn weight practices this is the one
we're going to live in today this is the
code we're fixing and if you don't
remember everything we covered that's
okay because it's already fixed inside
of good asyn weight practice so let's
dive in so this first refactor here
we're we're actually we're already
getting yelled at and we're already
getting yelled at because we're doing
exactly what I just told you not to do
right uh refresh is an async task method
and we're not awaiting it but you know
here we are in the Constructor of the
class and so you know I just I just
stood up in front of everybody and said
always await every task but we're in the
Constructor Constructors can't use asent
KO because Constructors aren't designed
for that the whole point of a
Constructor is just to initialize your
object it's literally assigning a slot
in memory to put this object into and
then you know we can use it to assign
some variables but you're not supposed
to do any sort of long run thing in a
Constructor because again we're just
initializing the object assigning it to
a location of memory so we'll never be
able to use the awake keyword in the
Constructor but so how do we get around
this well there is one cool trick
here we can use
an async void method to get away from to
get away from that error now you might
be thinking to yourself hold up I was
told never to use asyn void and and
you're not wrong um but the problem I
have with that that method of teaching
because I'm sure we've all been in a
class or watched a video when somebody
says never use async void it's only
meant for event handlers and yeah if you
subscribe to that then you'll be in
pretty good position but this is
actually a valid case of acing FOID and
the problem I have when people tell us
never to use it is they don't tell you
why so so why is this code dangerous
because if we look at it we're we're
covering everything we just talked about
in the beginning right because refresh
is an acing task method and we're using
we're calling the await keyword so that
means if an exception is thrown I'll be
able to it'll surface it'll be uh
visible to me because the awake keyword
will rethrow that exception
and and honestly this is good code you
could push this to production but let's
talk about why this is dangerous so uh
one of the reasons why this is dangerous
is if we go back to that first example
where let's say thread one calls refresh
so thread one comes into this method and
it hits the awake keyword and just like
we learned it's going to return and now
a different thread let's say thread two
is running this method called ref fresh
um but what's really happening is thread
one's returning to here so thread one's
going to return here to continue
executing code executing code
now why this is dangerous is we've got a
couple things going on here so the first
thing
is this method let's say you know let's
say it doesn't exist right here like
it's very much in our face here if we
were looking at code we would hopefully
see this acing void right in our face uh
but let's what if it was in a different
class let's say this is code I didn't
write maybe it's a library right that I
don't even have insight into what's
going on under the hood uh when I call
this method and I look at intellisense
and I see intellisense tells me this
method returns void as C developers
we're rightly Justified into assuming
that this refresh method will finish
running before it goes to this line and
that's totally valid you will never be
wrong for assuming that a void method
finishes running before it moves to the
next next line of code um so one of the
reasons this is dangerous is if we look
down at refresh you know it's it's
getting the top stories we have our top
Story collection that it's going to be
adding the stories into and in a sorted
way because Hacker News likes to sort
things by points so you can see people
up vote and down vote stories and that's
how they bubble up to the top um but
what if here I was playing around with
top Story collection to and maybe my
code here is adding things or maybe I'm
clearing it and and now what our code or
the problem in our code is that thread
one is modifying top Story collection
well at the same time in the background
on a different thread thread two is also
modifying top Story collection so we're
going to get weird Behavior here and so
this is one of the reasons why async
void is dangerous because there's
there's no way to await a void method so
so we don't we we don't like that um but
another reason that async void's super
dangerous is let's say this method does
throw an exception so we'll just
hardcode throw to exception here just to
really drive home that issue uh you
might think to yourself well okay no big
deal you know I'll just I'll wrap this
in a try try catch
block and I'll just catch it right
what's the big deal that's that's how do
net works we just catch the exception
and we probably do nothing with it cuz
that's how we work inet um but the
problem with this again is let's say
again picture it right thread one comes
into here thread one enters the triy
catch block thread one calls refresh
thread one comes down here hits the
awake keyword and now it's returned it's
left uh the refresh method and because
we're not awaiting refresh thread one's
now back here and it's just going to
continue on and now thread one's all the
way down here out outside of our Tri
catch block meanwhile thread 2 in the
background is still running this and
eventually it's going to throw an
exception but we've already exited the
tri catch block so another reason why
async void is dangerous is because it's
kind of almost nearly impossible to
catch exceptions that come out of an
async void method
so what are we going to do now right um
so let's actually let's back way way up
because we do want to avoid asyn void
that's it's good advice it's good advice
to avoid using asyn void methods but
there are valid use cases as we saw here
and so an option we do have and
something I've created is this extension
method called safe fire and forget and
if we dig into the source code here
because we're actually in the library
for safey and forget we can see how it
works and what I'm doing under the hood
for you is I'm taking your task I'm
awaiting it and then I have some code
here to handle exceptions so if we jump
back for example we could say if an
exception does happen and let's say
we'll just tell it to catch every
exception then we can handle that
exception here um and this is using
async void but the nice thing about safe
fire and forget is it's really in your
face like if you're looking at this code
you
know just by seeing this method that yes
I'm aware that this is a task and no I
don't want to await it I just want to
send it off to a background task and I
know so it's basically we're saying here
I know that my thread will continue on
well in this case refresh is running
so so what you can do uh again all this
code's open source but I'll show you
it's also up on nugit it's called async
AWA best practices so you're more than
welcome just to come in here copy paste
the code it's just an MIT license it's
open source that's what it's there for
um but I figured why not noua tize it
because I'm lazy too right I didn't want
to have to copy this code into all my
apps and so you can come download asyn
weight best practices slap it into your
app we actually just passed over a
million downloads which is really really
cool uh
and so if a million people are using it
it's got to be good right and
then and then we know again we want to
fire and forget this task we want to run
it in the background and this is way way
way better than what we were talking
about earlier where we would do task.
run dot dot dot task. run without
awaiting it super super dangerous safe
fire and forget pretty cool okay so
we're going to keep that safe fire and
forget and we're done refactoring ing
this method here so let's move on to the
next one so this is the method called
refresh this is the method that executes
anytime we do a pull to refresh on the
app and you know one of the reasons why
I'm calling it here in the Constructor
is I want the app to automatically
refresh and go get the new stories as
soon as the user opens it like how how
terrible of that of an experience would
it be if you launch my app nothing
happens and then you have to manually uh
like swipe to refresh that'd be terrible
so so that's why we're calling the
Constructor um but what I have here is a
little trick that we do in mobile apps
because sometimes the results come back
really fast and users don't don't
believe it um so for better or worse I
actually inject a task. delay into a lot
of my apps so that we get consistency
because especially with mobile apps if
you do a pulled to refresh and the
results come back right away see how it
just disappeared it doesn't look like
anything happened you're going to go ah
what the heck and you're probably going
to force quit the app and give me
another one star review so as weird as
it sounds this is a really common
practice where you know it'll always
display that activity indicator at the
top for two seconds and we do that or I
do that by having this minimum refresh
time and I'm doing it by calling task.
delay and then down here I'll make sure
we wait until that task is done so even
if all this code completes in 5
milliseconds that'd be insane but even
if it does you're still going to see
that activity indicator show up for 2
seconds to let you know that I heard you
I did it we're good um so so what's
wrong with this code well this isn't bad
because we're gonna we're going to await
this task later so we can we can kick it
off here as like a little timer and then
we can await it later um but something
that we're missing here is I have a
cancellation token refresh gives me a
cancellation token token and I'm not
using it here and that's a bad practice
we should always be using cancellation
tokens for all of our async task methods
so if we're ever writing a async task
method we should give the consumer of
the method the ability to pass in a
cancellation token because otherwise how
are they going to stop it if they want
to so it's always a best practice to do
that and something cool that I want to
show you is we can take that
cancellation token and we can just slap
it on to the end of a task so what we're
looking at here is task. delay obviously
returns a task and for any method that
returns a task and let's say you know
those Library creators aren't as smart
as we are they don't know about these
best practices like we do and they don't
give us the option to pass in a
cancellation token well there's this
cool extension method that lives Inn net
now called weight async that allows us
to essentially bolt on on a cancellation
token to any method that we want that
returns a task so this is really cool
because sometimes developers don't
sometimes developers don't give us that
option to pass in a cancellation token
and now it doesn't matter we can just
basically bolt on this cancellation
token If This Were to uh if we were to
cancel this token then it would cancel
this task that it's attached to now all
that to say that was just kind of a
convenient excuse to show it because
test. delay actually does accept a
cancellation token so kudos to the net
team on writing good net
code all right next refactor so now what
we're looking at is this method that
calls get top stories so just like we
talked about we want to go to The Hacker
News API we want to get the latest top
stories off of Hacker News and then we
want to display them onto the screen
so this looks pretty good right like
we're calling a
weit we're inside of an acing task
method what's bad about this well again
let's think about what's going on under
the hood so let's assume thread one
kicks off this method so thread one
comes into here thread one spins up
task. delay there's no await keyword yet
so thread one's still going and we come
here we come here and then we hit this
awake keyword and now thread one returns
so great because we don't want thread
one getting the a or hitting the apis
for us because if this takes 5 seconds
and thread one's locked up for five
seconds making API calls our apps Frozen
for 5 seconds um
but this isn't great because even though
a different thread's doing it let's say
a background thread thread 32 is is
running G top stories well when G top
stories is done remember we return back
to the calling thread so once get top
stories finishes once the task is
completed Net's going to go hey thread
one you're back up and then thread one
jumps in here here and that's what
clears our collection and then run to
this for each Loop and is that really
what we want I mean I don't because I
want thread one to be free I want thread
one to stay ready to listen to the user
interact with them scroll draw do
whatever the user wants to do that's
what I want thread one focused on but as
we just saw thread one's kind of getting
hijacked to come back in so one thing we
can do here let's do it in line first we
can tack on configure a we false so
configure we false kind of like uh what
we saw just a second ago with DOT weight
async this is an extension method that
again bolts onto the task so it doesn't
affect the task but what it does it
tells do net I don't need to return to
the calling thread it tells net hey when
I'm done when get top stories is
completed grab any thread from the
thread pool Don't Wait For Thread one
and this is really cool because you know
what if you know this is a pretty simple
app sure but what if I made a game and
there's a lot of you know the screen's
constantly moving I'm constantly drawing
objects on the screen really really
working thread one well if I had to
return to thread one I got to wait till
thread one's ready so if thread one's
busy drawing stuff on the screen it
might be a little while I mean little
while right like micros seconds we're
talking but a little while we're just
kind of hanging out here our coach is
kind of hanging out it's like yep
everybody's ready but thread 's still
busy so guess we'll just wait so by
tacking on configur O8 false we tell net
I don't care and for me as as a mobile
app developer uhet Maui developer
everything we do is in the mvvm
architecture so if I have any other mvvm
fans out there my rule of them is if I'm
not in my view layer so for mvvm that
means I'm in my view model layer I'm in
my services layer I'm somewhere where
this code doesn't touch the UI this is
all business logic so if I'm in my view
model layer I know none of this code
touches the UI then I configure a weight
false everywhere um the I'll say the one
downside about configure weight false is
once you learn about it you're going to
start adding it everywhere
and yeah Denny does and then once you
once you do you kind of wish there was a
default but there's no default uh
there's no way to tell net hey let's
make configurate false to default
because I've got a thousand async
methods
99,999 of them want configurate false
and I only want this one to say
configurate true so I'll let you know
for that one but now we have to pen
configurate false everywhere I've been
trying to poke the net team to get them
to let us add a default for it but until
then we'll just depend configurate false
and again this means that we don't
return to the calling thread so our code
will execute a little bit more quickly
and in the case of this this app that it
free keeps the UI thread UI thread free
to interact with the user all right so
check that one off coming down all right
now we're in the finally block and we're
back to that minimum refresh time task
so again this is just a task. delay that
I kicked off up here so when I
initialized this variable when I called
task. delay it started running so this
timer this this 2cond timer started
running
way back here and now I just want to
make sure it's been at least 2 seconds
before I tell the UI to stop refreshing
to remove that little spinny activity
indicator at the top um but the problem
here is I'm calling dot weight now if
there's one thing you take away from
this session today it's never never
never never never never never never call
weightweight is really really dangerous
and I'll tell you why so witht weight
What's Happening Here
is let's say Say thread five we're on
thread five now so thread five comes
into here and it hits minimum refresh
time task and it's still got about a
second left before so with DOT weight
what happens is you know like we talked
about up here normally when a thread
sees a weight it returns it either goes
back to the thread pool or if it's the
main thread it goes back to the UI and
to the user uh but with weight weight
says no no no no you don't get to go
anywhere you're gonna stay right here so
weight hijacks that calling thread and
says you stay here and it still spends
up another thread for that background
thread so now with DOT weight we have
two things that are really bad the first
being if we call that on thread one the
main thread well we've just locked our
main thread and now our app's Frozen
until this is done and we're using two
threads when when we only should be
using one so even if you don't write any
code that has UI maybe you're sitting
there going ah Brandon I I make apis I'm
a I'm a backend developer who cares
about whether the UI gets tho gets
frozen well remember your server has a
finite number of threads in its thread
pool and so if you're calling weight on
the server side even though there's no
UI to worry about freezing well every
time you called out wait you're using
two threads instead of one and
eventually that server is going to get
slammed you're going to hit what's
called threadpool exhaustion where now
all the threads are used up and your
server's basically crippled so not only
is weight bad because it'll freeze our
UI if that if we call it on the on the
UI thread but it also cause our servers
to hit that threadpool exhaustion more
quickly so the right way to do this is
just to await this task and we can even
call configurate false here like I said
I I put it everywhere in my view model
so you'll be seeing that a lot today um
but let me let me just show you
something real quick because you know
it's it's super rare nowadays it's super
super rare but there is still a
0.001% chance that you might have to
call do weight maybe there's an old
library you're using that a developer
created before asyn a weight existed
before task existed and the only way to
do it is to call do weight well if
you're in this case and again this
should be very rare
99.999% of the time you should not be
using dot weight but if we're in this
scenario what we actually want to call
is get a
waiter get result now this is still not
great geta waer get result does
literally the same thing it's still
going to hijack that calling thread it's
going to say nope thread one you stay
right here well I spin up another thread
to execute this in the background so
we're still locking the calling thread
we're still using two threads when we
only should be using one but we get
better exception
handling if that's the right word for
this um so one of the problems with
weight and maybe you've seen this
is if if this code were to throw an
exception like yeah this is just task.
delay it's probably not going to throw
an exception unless this token gets
cancelled but let's pretend this is a a
long running method and it does throw an
exception weight does rethrow that
exception for us so just like the await
keyword rethrows the exception that gets
caught inside of move next weight will
do that but when weight throws an
exception it throws what's called a
system. agregate exception and those are
a little weird and it's an aggregate
exception is an exception that can hold
exceptions so it makes sense why the net
team did this because maybe there was a
couple exceptions thrown inside of our
uh inside of our task so it wants to
Bubble Up all of those to us um but for
debugging for reading stack traces it
makes things a lot more difficult uh
especially for new developers so if
you've never seen a system. aggregate
exception before you might not know that
you have to actually dig another layer
into it to find the exceptions that are
the collection of exceptions inside the
aggregate exception and especially with
new developers you know those can be
really uh difficult to understand and
track down so if we instead use geta wa
or get result again it does the same
dangerous bad behaviors. weight we don't
want to do this but if we have to
uh get wa get result get a waiter G
result is a little bit better because
it'll actually rethrow our exception so
whatever exception happened in our code
that's the exception we get back from
geta wait or got get result so it'll
make your life easier but in this case
we don't got to do that we're inside of
async task method so we're going to do
best practices and call just a weight
and configure weight false and if you
didn't know yes you can use async a
weight inide of finally
blocks okay next on the list so we've
got our GP stories method and if we look
at it we're making actually two API
calls so The Hacker News API is a little
a little hokey I wish it was better but
you have to first make a call to say hey
give me all the IDS for the top stories
and then they give you the IDS and then
you make another API call for each story
that you have to iterate over to get
each of them back so it's not great you
know why not just give it to me all at
once I just want the top stories like
what else is Hacker News for other than
the top stories but this is the way they
designed it um and oh something cool
before I forget this is a a new little
toy inside ofet 8 uh this has nothing to
do with asyn weight but I wanted to show
it off here because I am a huge huge fan
of immutability so when when I make API
calls in my apps and I get data back
from another source SCE I don't want
that data to change I've been using I
readon list the interface I readon list
instead of list because that actually
will store things inside of a list and
you can't change it well in net 8 they
came out with this new namespace called
system. collections. Frozen and one of
them is called Frozen set and there's
also Frozen dictionary and kind of
similar to a readon list or an mutable
list uh this allow this will make sure
nothing changes inside you know one of
the problems with I readon list
is you could still change something if
you worked hard enough you could still
you know make a reference to something
inside of it and swap them out you know
with reference types. net can get a
little hokey like that and we can kind
of hack our own code accidentally a
little bit but Frozen set it'll never
change so that's why I've got this here
because I want to get these top stories
back up here and I always want that
pure data that came back from the API
because who knows maybe you gotta you
got to double check it later like hey
what what data actually did come back
and if we already modified that data
that'd be bad so welcome to Frozen set
but back to asyn stuff so we're looking
at this code here and what are we doing
we're getting those top story IDs so we
got them and then once we get those IDs
we have to iterate over them like I said
this this API kind of sucks because now
I've got to one by one get make 50 API
calls to get 50 stories so I got to make
this API call get a new story add it to
the list I got to make another API call
get the story add to the list and you
know if each API call takes 10 seconds
and I'm making 50 50 of them serially
well my users aren't going to like that
so so what can we do here well instead
of rewriting this I'm going to jump over
here to the good async way practices to
show you something that's really really
cool
inside of net now that we can utilize
and it's called I async inumerable
so with i async inumerable
before we look at the code before we
look at that rewrite let's look at how
we use it so in the good code here this
is our refresh method again but you know
we're passing in cancellation tokens
best practices um and then here now we
see this await for each Loop and this is
really really cool because if we look at
the bad code side by side the bad code
when it calls get
stories it just has to wait till all
those stories have been retrieved so
again it's just sitting there for let's
say 500 seconds while we make 50 API
calls and then it can display them on
the screen with IAS sync innumerable we
have this await for each
Loop let's make this full
screen where we can basically pass in an
async method get top stories is an async
method um it's a little weird because
it's returning async inumerable instead
of task but we can still use the async
keyword we can still use the awake
keyword um but what's cool is
once one story is
retrieved I can take action on it and if
I if I relaunch the app
here this is running with the good view
model so the good practices you'll see
the app updates in real time it doesn't
wait for each to come back I'm able to
kick off 50 background tasks and then as
they finish I can Surface them to the
user so even if and you know mobile
phones are fickle maybe you're on the
bus maybe the you go through a tunnel
your internet connection sucks we're at
a conference where there's terrible
Wi-Fi although I think the Wi-Fi has
been pretty good here so far at least
for me uh we we don't want the user just
sitting there looking at like just
little spinning indicator it's so much
better if we can start giving them the
data first or as as we're waiting for
all of it to finish rather so so how
does this work this is and this is a
little weird if you've never implemented
in iyn inumerable before um it's going
to feel a little icky but man the
results are so good that it's totally
worth it um so the first thing I want to
point out is these parameters so like I
mentioned earlier we always want to be
able to pass in a cancellation token if
we're making an async task method or
even an async i async enumerable method
um give me the option to give you a
cancellation token because if it's taken
more than 10 seconds maybe I just want
to call it off so we can still do that
but I think nurmes got some extra logic
in it that we can take advantage of so
there's this enumerator cancellation
attribute and if we assign that here as
our cancellation token parameter to our
cancellation token parameter now now
this I async inumerable knows that if
this token is ever
cancelled stop so and again we shouldn't
but let's say none of our methods in
here accepted cancellation token so
we're not we're not doing anything with
this cancellation token it's not being
used anywhere um that's okay because
thewait for each Loop will automatically
break its iteration once it sees that
this cancellation token has completed as
long as we put this attribute in it now
should we ignore it no we should always
pass in those cancellation tokens so
let's put them back here um so keep that
in mind I think you do get yelled at I
think I'll get a do I get a squiggle oh
wait where'd it
go if I get rid of just that part yeah
we get a little bit of a squiggle there
so it's letting me know that you've got
a what's exactly it say you've got a
there we go we should decorate with the
enumerator cancellation Togo and
attribute blah blah blah blah blah so if
you forget hopefully that's enough to
remind you as well um but yeah if we
look at this code the way we take a
method
like this
where we are in the bad way doing a four
each Loop and iterating over one story
at a time and turn that into an isync
inumerable
is we basically use a list of tasks so I
I created this new list of task of type
story Model because that's that's what
my API returns back so the API is going
to give me a task of type story Model
and what I do I say hey for every top
Story
ID basically kick off that task so kick
it off in the background like this get
story right
here this returns a task but I'm not
awaiting it I'm just putting all those
tasks into a list because then what I do
is I put it in a while loop and I say
get top story task list. any if that's
still true keep iterating through here
and what we get is or what we can do is
we can take advantage of task. when any
so task. when any totally totally cool
um what it does is you pass into task.
when a collection so you pass in an
inumerable
and anytime or rather to be more
specific you pass in an inumerable of
type t
so if you have a list of tasks you can
pass those into task. when any and as
soon as one of those tasks is completed
it'll return it to me so I say a wait t.
when any of course configurate false and
I get this completed get story task here
so the first thing I do is I remove that
from my list because I know it's done I
don't need to I don't need to await it
anymore and then I get the result from
that story and I call yield return now
if you're familiar with I inumerable
you've maybe done a yield return before
um but maybe you're not like who who
uses yield return really anymore for I
innumerables I don't but for I async
innumerable what yield return does and
the reason it's so beneficial is as soon
as we hit this yield return our code
jumps into this for each block so now
the yield return happens and we can
iterate on what just that one result we
got back and then the code returns back
here to resume the while loop so in this
manner we're able to kick off all the
background tasks we need and then we can
show them to the user as they complete
so super super useful like I said
creating a list of tasks is a little
weird and then a weight dot task. whenn
is a little weird but man the the
benefits of isnc and neurable huge huge
huge so highly highly recommend that for
all of our
apps just so we don't have to leave the
user sitting there waiting for something
to happen all right so let's pretend
like we refactored that here we're a
little low on time so I'm not going to
rewrite this whole method for us all
right so next
one we've got a method called get story
This Is Calling The Hacker News API it's
getting the story cancellation tokens
good um we're not doing configur weight
fall so let's slap that in there that'd
be good but what else could we do
because we're using a weight we're using
async configure false well something
that's kind of cool here is that if we
look at the return type of get story it
returns a type of task story Model and
if I look at my method My Method
signature it also returns a type of task
story Model and the only place in this
method where I'm using the awake keyword
is in the return statement so something
I can
do I can get get rid of async I can get
rid of a
weight and I can just return that task
now why is this good why would I want to
do this well let's put those back and
think about what's going on again so
again let's pretend thread one kicks off
this method so thread one jumps into get
story and immediately hits the awake
keyword so thread one leaves we grab a
background thread now thread 52 is
running get story in the background when
thread 52 is done it's going to well
this case we have configurate false so
it won't return to the calling thread
it'll let net know hey I'm all done so
with configurate false net just goes to
the thread pool grabs whatever threads
free and let's say thread seven now
returns this method so what just
happened was with this one line of code
we had to switch threads twice and if we
can avoid that we should because
switching threads switching context is
expensive in net so if we get rid of
async get get rid of a weight and just
return that task essentially what we're
doing is
deferring that context switch that
thread change up to whoever calls this
method so wherever I got in the code
where are we calling it up here so up
here where we call awake get story it's
returning that task that we just
returned so so by just returning the
task we can save a little bit on async
of weight our codee's going to run a
little bit faster and we got rid of the
asyn keyword so our code gets a little
bit smaller I mean 100 btes smaller but
still a little bit smaller now I've got
one more down here um and this one's
kind of similar right I mean the only
real difference is we've got this if
statement to you know instead of getting
the top story IDs every time like do
they really change that much and if
we've already retrieved them and they've
done a pull the user does another pull
to refresh well I said if it's only been
an hour just use the ones we already got
we don't need to make another API call
so that's a little different we've got a
try catch block here but like I was just
saying if the only place we're using the
awake keyword is in the return
statement we can get rid of it and this
up here will yell at us because we have
to say from result just to pass that
into a task since we do have to return a
task and this is good
right no this is actually really bad so
this is the exception um so this is fine
up here but down here we're inside of a
tri catch block so if we think about
what happens is let's say our code comes
in the thread gets to here and then the
thread hits this return statement it
returns we've we've exited this method
which means we've exited this TR catch
block so now if this method throws an
exception we're never going to catch it
here because we've already left we've
already returned so so we can't do that
actually so in this case because we're
inside of a tri catch block and we want
to catch that exception be able to
handle it we do actually want to return
a weight so most of the times if the
only place in your method where you use
the awake keyword is in the return
statement you can just return the task
but in cases like this where we're
inside of a TR catch block or maybe
we're inside of a using block like we're
disposing of an object make sure to keep
the return await because speaking from
experience you're going to get real
weird bugs in your app and you're like
why didn't this why didn't this bug get
caught I catch I got a catch right here
so we're going to keep this AWA in here
we're going to keep configure a weight
false um but what we can do to refactor
this method is we can use something
called a value task now a value task is
kind of similar to a task on the surface
it feels super super super super similar
like if I look at the code that calls
this method I still await it I still can
basically treat it like a task um but
with a value task it's a value type so
in net we have value types and we have
reference types value types get put onto
a stack reference types get put onto a
heap and if you remember from your data
structures days adding something to a
stack super quick super simple you just
popping it or push it into the top
putting something on a heap more
expensive because a heap has to be
indexed so adding something to a heap is
a little bit more expensive and the
reason we can use value task here is
because of this part of the code right
here so if we look at the
code the first time we call it we're not
going to have anything our data is not
going to be recent so we're not going to
return here we're going to come down
here and call the API but then the user
does a pull to refresh and the second
time this code runs we're going to
return right away and the third time
this code runs we're going to return
right away and for the whole next hour
the next time this code runs we're going
to return right away and if you have a
scenario like this where you have a
method where the hot path where
something like this where nine times out
of 10 you're going to return without
ever using the awake keyword you can
return a value task and you get a nice
little performance bump so you don't
want a value task everywhere if if your
method always calls the awake keyword
keep using a task that's what it's there
for but with value task we get a little
bit of a performance bump because we
don't have to go through all the
overhead of creating a task and putting
out the Heap and they're a little bit
more complex than value tasks anyway so
we can take advantage of that here and
again our app now works a little a
little bit
faster okay so let's let's do a quick
review like I said this is years and
years this is like what 15 years of
async weight content smash into an hour
so what do we talk about well never use
weight never use do result we didn't
show do result in the examples but it
does the same thing that weight does
it's going to lock the calling thread
it's going to keep it it's going to hold
it hostage while the other background
threads going we're going to be using
two threads we should only be using one
so instead we should just use the awake
keyword but if in that really really
rare instance where we can't use a
weight we should use get a weit or get
result and get a wait or get result
actually replaces both it has the same
behavior as that weight and it has the
same behavior as result so we can go
through all of our code and hopefully
replace replace weight with a weight but
again in the rare instance where you
have to get a wait or get
result fired forget task so if you want
to run a task on a background thread
that's totally cool I do it all the time
myself feel free to grab my n package
ASN await best practices and then you
can use that fire and forget extension
method or if your company doesn't like
you adding new get packages you can just
copy paste the code that's totally cool
too avoid return a weit so like we saw
earlier if we're if the only place in
our method where we use the awake
keyword is in the return
statement we could just return the task
except if you're in a TR catch block or
if you're in a using block again this is
totally from experience I I return out
of a using block once and all of a
sudden I'm getting object disposed
errors because what I was trying to do
in the background that object got
disposed so learn from my pain learn
from my examples if you're using a TR
catch block if you're inside of a using
block keep the return
await utilize configurate false so if
you don't need to return to that calling
thread configurate false will help your
code run a little bit faster there is a
caveat to this net has something called
a synchronization context in most
Frameworks uh so I've listed out a
couple the popular ones or at least the
ones I could think of off the top of my
head um and kind of a rule of thumb is
if it's got a UI it probably has
synchronization context because the
whole point of a synchronization context
is to be able to help Net return to the
UI thread so if you have a UI there's a
likely likely chance that you have a
synchronization context and if that's
the case configure weight false will
never return back to that calling thread
um if there is no config if there is no
synchronization context like for example
asp.net core doesn't have a conf
configuration context synchronization
context so in asp.net core you can still
use configure weight false I actually do
it's partly out of habit and partly kind
of best practices because I copy paste
code from a lot of places a lot so I
just want to follow best practices I
still use it in asp core but because
asp.net core does not have a
synchronization context calling configur
rate false is the same thing as calling
configur rate true they they don't make
a difference because that whole
configure weight is actually telling the
synchronization context whether or not
to returned back to the calling thread
so little caveat there uh value task so
again if the hot path of your method
does not use the await keyword if nine
times out of 10 that code in your method
will never call await have it return a
value task instead of a
task isnc inumerable like we saw this is
our await for each Loop so for streaming
data if we want to update the UI as uh
data returns back uh this will give a
much much better user experience just
keep in mind we do still want to use
cancellation tokens and make sure to
tell that for each Loop that await for
each Loop this enumerator cancellation
attribute to let it know that hey this
is your cancellation token so anytime
this cancels you're done you don't need
to keep
looping and we async so if you ever have
a method where the developer just didn't
allow you to include a cancellation
token or pass in a cancellation token
you can just bolt on a cancellation
token with this extension method do
weight async and it works just as if
they did so it's kind of a little
workaround for us for super super
helpful for backwards
compatibility last one and we actually
didn't cover this in the example code
mostly because I couldn't really come up
with a good example in this app to make
this work but if you've ever heard of I
disposable there's now an i async
disposable and it works super super
similar so we have our using block and
just like with I disposable when the end
of the when we reach the end of the
using block that object will be disposed
so in this case we're neing up file
stream we're going to write all our code
we saving data to a file and at the end
of this using block the file stream will
be disposed so we're being you know Good
Shepherd of our memory and good net
developers well kind of the same idea
with AWA using so there's certain
libraries like file stream that are kind
of heavy to initialize heavy to tear
down and we don't really want to do that
on the main thread so they've given us
now I async disposable and to use that
all we have to do is say await
using treat it exactly the same we can
even you can see at the end there at the
very very end it says do configurate
false so we can still tell it
configurate false and then the way this
works at the end of that block that's
when it'll actually await it so it's a
little the syntax makes sense and the
fact that it looks good um but it's a
little weird because that await doesn't
really happen till the end but it'll
still happen
so if you haven't had a chance yet this
is this is the time make sure to take
out your phones grab a picture of the QR
code grab this link because this is
where you can find all the resources
from today so I've uploaded all of the
slides from this presentation I've
uploaded a video from a previous time
I've given this talk so you don't have
to worry about memorizing anything you
can re-watch the video you can share it
with your co-workers um I've also
included a bunch of helpful links in
here so if you want to dive deeper into
value task you want to dive deeper into
isnc disposable you want to dive deeper
into isnc innumerable all those cool
things we talked about today are on that
website for you as
well thank
you
[Applause]